ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen mannschaft
hätte meine lieben freunde wir dürfen
gar nicht lange zeit verlieren denn mir
wurde und in die kommentare geschrieben
du kannst du deine hühnchen nicht nur
weiter vermehren indem du irgendwie die
eier von denen nimmt und das auf dem
boden haut ich kann von mir denn ich
kann die auch einfach fahren mit den
samen die statischen in der hand habe
und das ist ja alles cool sind ja nicht
irgendwie meine mutter oder so
um diese paarung der hühnchen jetzt mal
zu testen würde ich sagen wir legen wir
uns mal straight darüber direkt zur tier
insel hier vorne und während ich gerade
noch ein bisschen sitze kann ich euch
auch ganz kurz darüber informieren dass
ich ein neues foto oft instagram
hochgeladen habe interessiert niemanden
falls euch doch interessiert dann schaut
gern vorbei und münchen
hier ist 1 und hier vorne auch okay sie
haben sie direkt gefunden also hier
rechts auf die rechtskraft das klappt
und wir haben einen ich habe ein paar
sekunden auf der welt sein und jetzt
schon so als er zu mir sein wenn wir
jetzt allerdings schon mal hier sind
können wir auch mal ganz kurz unsere
anderen tierischen japan hier vorne zum
beispiel direkt die schweinchen dann
machen wir hier kurz rechts ich drauf
und hier dann haben wir ein neues baby
schweinchen am start jetzt jeden moment
sagt und jetzt können auch mal ganz kurz
das weizen nehme ich weiß allerdings
gerade nicht wenn wir miteinander paaren
können wir haben dort vorne ein
schiffchen und wir haben ich hier vorne
noch ein schippchen also kommen bitte
mit und du mit dem hier einmal ganz kurz
sakhir beiden können mal ganz mittwoch
ein kind kriegen und wir haben hier noch
eine kuh und wo war denn noch eine
andere kuh du bitte einmal ganz kurz
noch mal eben mit ihnen ihr euch
fortpflanzen dass wir auf jeden fall
auch super dann bekommen wir noch eine
kleine neue baby co und die tier insel
wird mehr und mehr zum leben erwacht
alter sie das schön aus
ich bin so glücklich über unsere welt da
hinten einfach mit dem piratenschiff
[Musik]
[Applaus]
haltet euer maul es ist allerdings
eigentlich auch ganz gut dass wir jetzt
gerade mal kurz darauf der tier insel
hier sind denn in der heutigen episode
habe ich ein riesiges ziel und zwar
möchte ich ja die hbh dort hin bauen die
angeln und bootshütte und dafür brauchen
wir noch eine menge mehr eichenholz
[Musik]
so ich habe dort gerade eine menge bäume
ab gefällt ich habe jetzt locker
anderthalb stacks mehr eichenholz und
ich habe auch alles wieder neu bepflanzt
also dort die ganzen setzlinge
selbstverständlich wieder hingesetzt
dementsprechend packe ich auch diese
dinge jetzt noch mal ganz kurz in die
kiste rein ich hoffe mal dass das jetzt
hier reichen sollte an holz und das hier
packe ich auch noch mal eben kurz rein
und den respektiere ich eben und geht
dann schlafen und dann sehen uns hier am
nächsten tag wieder wenn es losgeht mit
dem bau von der angel und bootshütte die
wird sehr riesig ich habe auch ein sehr
großes ding von la paz ein neuer morgen
erwartet uns hier in unserer kleinen
süßen mannschaft fällt meine lieben
freunde wir sehen schon hier hinten die
bäume fangen wieder an zu wachsen und
wir fangen nun auch endlich an mit
unserem plan für die heutige episode
nämlich die angebote habe ich ja gerade
schon gesagt ich hab' und guck mal das
alles wieder gewachsen und so darum soll
es heute allerdings nicht gehen wir
können hier vorne noch mal ganz kurz den
bauern hier generell so ein bisschen
kleiner machen bzw
das laufen bisschen entfernt fällt mir
gerade so auf wir haben das ja damals
auf der einen seite entfernt damit ich
mir den kopf stoße an dem lauf wenn ich
den weg runter laufe aber dann haben wir
so jetzt auch mal ein bisschen klima und
der baum sieht nicht mehr nur auf einer
seite abgehakt außerdem an dass sie aber
auch nicht das war zu viel wie die oat
von daher hier wieder ein hin rabatt.de
hier haben wir auf jeden fall weg nehmen
dann ist das hier ein bisschen china aus
und hier müssen wir noch ganz kurz
warten bis hier der weg nur weg so dass
wir hier auch ein trampelpfad machen
können die sache ist allerdings dass wir
jetzt erstmal hier vorne diese drei
stufen wegnehmen werden denn das wird er
setzt den durch die stufen die wir hier
vorne drin haben die alten holzstufen
die kommen hier nämlich so schon lange
die sache ist allerdings dass wir den
weg ja so ein bisschen auslaufen lassen
müssen von daher würde ich den hier zwar
noch wegnehmen
hier vorne dann allerdings den weg noch
auslaufen lassen und dann hier geht's
dann los in richtung bot ich brauche mal
ganz kurz den weg
so soll das hier vornehmlich aus sehen
wir haben hier so falltüren da können
wir hier auch noch mal eben eine
hinsetzen und dann geht das hier so ein
bisschen darüber dass sie sich jetzt mal
ein bisschen blöd aus mit der erde aber
das wird ja zu gras und dann geht der
weg hier vorne lang leben hier können
wir auch noch mal ganz kurz jetzt eben
ausgleichen
sieht auf jeden fall definitiv schöne
aus dass wir jetzt auch eine kleine
fläche haben genauso wie er hier vorne
vor unserem häuschen allerdings soll sie
dann so runter gehen und das wird auch
noch größer nach da hinten hin deswegen
musste ja noch ein bisschen mehr
eichenholz und die sache ist allerdings
dass wir jetzt hier auch erst mal den
weg umziehen werden und hier noch die
letzten drei reihen die sache ist jetzt
allerdings dass wir das hier wieder
abbauen werden denn hier kommen auch
fichtenholz fall schön hin dass wird so
ein kleiner weg hier von der seite rüber
dementsprechend nehme die jetzt ganz
kurz und so ziehen die zack zack zack
und hier auch nochmal drei stück 1 2 und
3 und jetzt benötigen wir unsere
eichenholz treppen beziehungsweise sogar
noch ein paar mehr habe ich ja hier
ziemlich viele mehr machen können und
erstmals auch noch ganz kurze unten die
sachen holen wir dürfen nämlich nichts
verschwenden wir brauchen wirklich so
viel materialien für dieses ganze
projekt die treppen kommen hier nämlich
so ran zack zack und hier vorne auch
wieder zack so ein bisschen wie in
unserer strandvilla da hinten die ja
noch nicht mal ansatzweise fertig ist
nur halt ein bisschen umgekehrt also
hier halt eher so dass es nicht als als
bargeld sondern so wie in der
strandvilla mit den quartz treppen wie
wir das dort gemacht haben also hier
auch nochmal zeigen und zack und jetzt
kümmern wir uns ein bisschen hier vorne
um das basiert darauf stehen soll denn
hier kommt unsere fischerhütte hin
also 2 davon und eichenholz obendrauf ja
auch zwei oder eichenholz obendrauf
hiervon auch wieder zwei abstand zack
zack und auch einen oben drauf und hier
vorne dann auch noch passend zu den
anderen zacken auch ein obendrauf
das wirkt jetzt relativ klein als
kleines häuschen aber das soll ja auch
nicht also riesig werden wir haben da
vorne an holz wir haben eine biene was
genau kann ich eigentlich mit diesem
binnenmarkt schwer es ist so schön wie
das da steht aber wir konzentrieren uns
hier heute auf dieses range und
bootshaus ecke aids angesteckt noch
peinlicher hier vorne das eichenholz hin
und hier eine fichtenholz
und hier sieht schon pferde aus aber von
hier ja hier vorne ziehen wir dann das
ganze auf jeden fall auch mit eichenholz
brettern hoch und genau das gleiche
spiegeln wir auch hier für die andere
seite der hier sollte nicht sein wir mal
ganz kurz wieder ab
und jetzt eben unser eichenholz treppen
und setzen diese und so hin und in die
mitte eine eichenholz falltür das habe
ja schon öfter so gemacht dass wir fall
schön einfach als fenster benutzern hier
vorne auch und hier vorne machen wir das
ganze so mit den treppen genauso wie wir
das hier vorne unten gemacht haben da
kommen dann zwei einzige mauern drauf
und darüber auch noch mal drei eichen
holzbretter für das dach nehmen wir
einzige treppen und setzten die ich so
soundso hin und das gleiche auf der
anderen seite hier auch zack zack und
zack auf der seite da vorne wird es ein
bisschen anders gemacht doch jetzt
brauchen wir erstmal noch unsere stein
ziegel stufen denn die setzen wir so und
dann muss ich mich einmal ganz kurz hoch
bauen zack zack da setzen wir hier oben
nämlich noch einen drauf dann baue ich
mir mal ganz kurz das hier wieder ab ich
weiß ich könnte auch meinen gerüst
nehmen was ich mir aus dem bambus
gemacht habe allerdings bin ich jetzt so
gewohnt dass hier mit meinen holz
beziehungsweise erde immer zu machen da
kann ich das auch noch ein bisschen
länger machen
mehr treppen habe ich gar nicht doch
hier sind am start das werden jetzt
nämlich auf der andern seite genauso
bauen allerdings ein bisschen anders
denn das wird nicht schon hier sein
sondern schon erst hier wird das so
anfangen hier keiner dran und hier vorne
machen wir das gleiche auch zack und
sagt dann fängt es nämlich schon hier
vorne an mit denen ich mir ein ganz kurz
auf treppen hoch jetzt fängt ziemlich
hier schon an mit unseren stein ziegel
dings zack und zack zack dann wollen wir
allerdings die hier mal eben wieder ab
und dann können wir jetzt nämlich völlig
entspannt eine laterne hinsetzen so dass
wir hier zumindest ein bisschen
beleuchtung haben die sonne geht schon
wieder unterhaltes gegen bewege ich mich
mal ganz schnell zu meinem
provisorischen betty vorn und die runde
schlafen
es ist ja eine richtige bau folge heute
also wenn ihr action wollt dann schaltet
einer der nächsten folgen wieder ein wo
wir dann wir hatten schon lange keine
externe ich freue mich auch ehrlich
gesagt wieder so ein bisschen auf inder
da ja immer noch eine menge quatsch
brauchen für unsere moderne strandhaus
oder da vorne wir konzentrieren uns nun
allerdings erstmals auf das dach von
unseren kleinen fischers häuschen hier
vorne
ich muss mich wieder hoch bauen nehmen
wir erst mal ganz kurz mein holz und das
dach soll nämlich aus in diesen reichen
holztreppen hier sein und hier auf der
anderen seite auch dann müssen wir das
allerdings hier vorne
das sehe glaube ich nicht gut sondern
eine treppe müssen wir das so hin
besetzen
deswegen nun erst mal ganz kurz
konzentration auf das sie an der seite
da setzen wir das nämlich wieder so hin
das haben wir bisher bei fast jedem dach
auf unserer insel so gemacht dass das
von unten dann auf jeden fall auch ganz
nice aussieht also hier zack zack und
von der seite aber normal und bam dann
können wir hier in die mitte das ganze
so setzen und dann zieht sich darüber
der giebel
ist es der giebel ich weiß es nicht ich
kenne mich damit nicht so gut aus
allerdings nur bis hierhin denn ab hier
haben wir dann wieder eine stein ziegel
stufe und auch wieder die steintreppen
die wir von der seite und von der seite
hier so hoch ziehen werden also hier
auch mal zack und dann jetzt auch noch
mal kurz hier drüber gesamt und hier
nochmal einen dran und hier wieder bam
bam und nun die letzten beiden zack und
sagt dann können wir den rest des daches
jetzt mit diesen reichen holztreppen
hier vorne machen wand und auf der
anderen seite der normale leben sagt
sagen drei vier und fünf von unten sieht
das ganze jetzt ein bisschen doof aus
weil das hier offen ist dafür nehmen wir
ganz einfach unsere alten holzbretter
und setzten die hier vorne hin
ich glaube die reichen jetzt nicht aus
für das was sie hier vorne noch brauchen
genau da brauchen wir noch ein paar mehr
ich weiß nicht ob ich noch welche in der
kiste habe das haben wir natürlich
natürlich nicht aber es kein problem
mehr machen wir uns hier einfach eben
kurz vier neue und nehmen die auch noch
für das hier nun müssen wir allerdings
auch noch ein bisschen beleuchtung dran
machen denn hier vorne muss auf jeden
fall noch eine lampe dran
wir benötigen wir keine das wird unser
eingang und hier vorne brauche jetzt mal
ein geländer hier aber noch probleme
darf habe ich immer neue zaun am start
also hier einfach mal alles passend
hinsetzen hier auf der seite auch das
war vorhin mein kleines pseudo gerüst um
darauf zu kommen hier vorne den weg und
so und jetzt zum zaun tore dazwischen
fragen mich ganz viele mal luca warum
sind am zaun tore das hat hier auch bei
meinem haus hier oben gemacht ob ich das
noch mal ganz kurz zu zeigen das ist
eigentlich auch richtig süß als eine
mischung irgendwie aus modernen hier
oben mit diesem glas und ihr und mit
diesem medium mäßigen look
das hatte ich ja auch gemacht ich finde
es einfach ganz schön wenn das hier
nicht mit dem boden verbunden ist und
wir müssen das echt mehr wertschätzung
öfter in den äther gehen allerdings soll
es ja heute nicht um den rapper gehen
sondern um eine abe hier vorne sieht
schon richtig heiß auswendig jetzt
müssen wir hier vorne allerdings erstmal
noch die gelände auch ein bisschen an
start bringen also wieder zack zack
und hier noch einen zaun hier vorne wird
es ein bisschen crazy da benötigen wir
erstmal noch unser fichtenholz unsere
zaun tore hier vorne
ich weiß gar nicht wie ich die jetzt
genau hin selbst ob ich die so hin setze
ich glaube ich setze die andersrum hin
also quasi an die teile hier dran dann
haben einen kleinen unterschied zu dem
weg hier vorne der herunter führt so und
so und genau das gleiche mache ich jetzt
hier vorne auch mal bamm bamm bamm bamm
bamm bamm michaela dass die vorne immer
so ein bisschen wenn ich hier so runter
gucke an so malediven urlaube also ich
war noch nicht auf den malediven aber
alles was man in den stories von
influenza und bloggern und so man sieht
die dort am start sind
da ist das so ganz ganz flaches wasser
aber dann trotzdem darüber gebaut so mit
holz und so sage ich ganz nice wo ist
die andere fichtenholz falsch ich glaube
die haben wir gerade schon aufgenommen
wir müssen auf jeden fall hier auch noch
einen draufsetzen allerdings kommt hier
noch mehr dran also sieht auch schon
hier vorne ist eine treppe dass wir noch
ein bisschen größer wir bauen - und
fischer's kran hin dass sinn ergibt aber
ihr seht auf jeden fall nachher was ich
meine
und dafür müssen wir auch diese beiden
hier noch mal eben abbauen zack und zack
die andere ist hier runtergeflogen
nämlich auch mal ganz kurz jetzt muss
ich von der seite wieder hoch ist ist
gerade ein bisschen stressig jetzt ist
allerdings ja auch eine bau folge und
mir gefallen diese bau folge ehrlich
gesagt auch mal ganz gut hier vorne
jetzt darauf konzentrieren dann machen
wir das nämlich so zack zack zack und
sagt und hier vorne war das ganze auch
einfach so soundso dann aber auf jeden
fall das geländer hier schon mal fertig
jetzt nehmen wir uns allerdings noch mal
ganz kurz in einen zaun und setzten den
hierhin so dass er so ein bisschen das
dach trägt also brauchen wir natürlich
nicht in minecraft generelle statik in
minecraft nierenproblemen aus labenz am
sand und kies geht
der kasse wirklich einfach so auf sand
turm kannst du den hochbau und dann
einfach darüber so riesig viel
bruchstein setzen ist ja auch egal hier
soll es heute nicht um physik gehen denn
ihr seht schon ich sollte mich gerade
wieder ein bisschen denn nun benötige
ich mein komplettes eichenholz und wir
werden dann
hier muss andere etwas aber irgendwie
noch erde hinsetzen oder so habe ich die
gerade hier habe ich sogar im staat
einmal ganz kurz vorher hin packen dann
wird das auch noch zu groß ich benötige
eine ganze reichen stämme und dann
können mal gucken ob das was wird
eventuell mit den ganzen sachen die ich
hier habe ich muss auf jeden fall auch
noch ein paar mehr hiervon machen sieben
stück sollten reichen
und jetzt euch jetzt mal ein ganz kurzer
zeit wie ich hier noch ein paar pfeile
hochziehen aus dem ozean so dass sie
haben wir auf jeden fall fertig die
sache ist allerdings dass ich nur noch
zwei holz unten habe das seht ihr ja
schon in einem inventar und das reicht
auf gar keinen fall also die stelzen
hier habe ich jetzt wirklich von unten
bis oben hochgezogen
ihr wisst ja ich möchte das hier alles
zusammen passen ich weiß ist dass auch
laufen würde wenn ich die einfach nur
vier hochbau allerdings hat es mich
wirklich bei der zauberinsel also hier
hinter wirklich total getriggert auf
dauer dass die teile nicht richtig mit
dem unterboden verbunden waren ich weiß
ich habe auch den kommentar gelesen das
ist bei meiner bilder insel auch nicht
so richtig sinn macht weil die komplette
insel irgendwie irgendwie komplett rum
[Musik]
das schaf stand einfach hier
und genau in dem moment wo der baum
gewachsen ist ist es da drin gestorben
ich würde sagen ich gehe jetzt mal ganz
kurz schlafen und setzt dem ein
reisebett hin und wenn das der
bürgermeister war alter dann haben wir
aber ein riesiges problem
dann müssen wir neuen bürgermeister
bestimmen wir haben ja eh nur drei
schafe auf dieser insel
das hier ist nicht der bürgermeister wir
haben eine 50 50-chance hh erlebt
[Musik]
ich glaube wir brauchen langsam echten
der grav insel ich weiß jetzt nicht wer
hier vorhin alles gestorben ist
allerdings waren es ja wirklich
verschiedene fleischsorten also es war
ja einmal groß hammelfleisch etwa rohes
schweinefleisch und rindfleisch das
hatte ich alles glaube ich vorher noch
nicht im inventar also da sind auf jeden
fall einige tiere gestorben ich kann die
nicht mehr hinten auf meinem grabstein
schreiben dass ich da war das spiel
eigentlich gerade ich kann die neben mir
auf meinem grabstein schreiben freunde
der ist schon voll das schild da vorne
deswegen ich habe jetzt auch gar kein
weizen dabei ich kenne jetzt sieben
paaren hier gerade außerdem scheine also
das machen wir irgendwann nachher auf
jeden fall der bürgermeister lebt auf
jeden fall noch und jetzt euch die ganz
kurze time natürlich das holz zusammen
suche
[Musik]
so ich habe einen halb sechs neue
eichenstämme unten im inventar seht ihr
schon ich habe auch die ganzen bäume
selbstverständlich wieder neu
angepflanzt und wir fahren direkt zurück
hier vorne zu unserer hbh zu unserer
angeln und bootshütte meine lieben
freunde nun geht es nämlich direkt
weiter hier vorne mit dem bereich wo wir
angeln werden dafür brauchen wir eine
menge züchten holz fallschirms auf jeden
fall deutlich zu wenig ich hoffe mal ich
hab mir noch ein paar mehr gemacht hier
vorne ich habe was
[Musik]
ich habe leider kein knochen mir mehr am
start deswegen müssen wir jetzt leider
mit den pflichten hinaus gaben die ich
mir gerade mit unserem fichtenholz
machen konnte das sind nämlich nur 25
stück die sache ist allerdings dass ein
paar bäume gewachsen sind und zwar haben
wir hier in wien es am start wir haben
hier plötzlich ein bienen des am start
und wir haben hier noch ein setzling wir
haben hier vorne noch ein bienen es am
start und sogar hier vorne noch irgendwo
1 glaube ich nicht glaube dass war sie
haben einfach drei neue minen es
plötzlich auf der insel besser hätte
eigentlich nicht laufen können und jetzt
stehen ja auch überall so ein paar
münchen herum gefahren ist doch eben
gerade eine kleine fichte gewachsen die
können auch mal eben kurz mitnehmen doch
dann müssen wir das leider mit dem
fichtenholz falschen irgendwann später
heute erst in der folge machen das
wollte ich eigentlich jetzt direkt
machen
das ist nämlich unser weg und das macht
halt sind das direkt zu machen
allerdings habe ich keine knochen mehr
und muss dementsprechend auf endlich
demnächst mal wieder in den netto also
ganz kurz wieder ins brötchen reisezweck
von unserer tieren sondern zurück zu
unserer insel
es sieht auf jeden fall schon sehr nice
aus hier vorne mit der hbh die sache ist
allerdings dass das ganze hier wirklich
noch ein deutliches stück größer wird
also ich mag mein brötchen erstmal hier
vorne denn hier sollen die auch
demnächst stehen einmal kurz
ausgestiegen und wir nehmen unsere
fichtenholz fallschirm und setzten die
jetzt hier vorne so daran
jetzt ziehen wir das hier vorne rüber
wir haben halt leider nur 22 stück ich
glaube wir brauchen noch für das
komplette projekt hier 20 stück mehr
oder so allerdings kann man sich das
ganze ja so glaube ich erst mal grob
vorstellen also der weg soll hat hier
runter gehen und dann weiter bis hier
vorne hin dann können wir uns hier mal
hinstellen und ab denn hier vorne kommt
auch noch eine kiste hin haben wir dann
unsere ganzen angeln und so drin und
dann geht hier vorne auch die sonne
unter und wir können immer so ein
bisschen drüber gucken zu unserer tier
insel
da sind auch gerade da vorne ist eine
neue wichtige wachsen und hier fordere
geht der weg hat zur seite rüber denn
hier und brötchen anlegen wir brauchen
jetzt ein bisschen beleuchtung hier am
start von daher nehmen wir hier einfach
unsere stein ziegelmauern setzen die
hierhin hier einfach beim so laternchen
drauf nehmen wir beispielsweise mal
wieder eine einzige stufe dann hier
wieder eine stein ziegelmauer und hier
vorne auch eine stein ziegelmauer dann
können wir hier wieder eine stein ziel
stufe nehmen das kann ich auch erstmal
ganz spezifische abfällen dass ein damit
ich ganz groß auf dieses dach da oben
drauf komme und hier vorne
dann können wir hier von hier können wir
theoretisch ein bisschen was verspielte
ritzen machen indem wir einfach eine
schwein ziegelmauern nehmen und dann
hier den zaun drauf dann müssen uns ja
allerdings ganz kurz wieder hoch bauen
an der seite zack zack zack
[Musik]
ich habe zwei sand eingesetzt okay hier
ein dass auch noch obendrauf nie hier
drauf und dann hier daran und hier vorne
an die seite auch könnt euch
wahrscheinlich schon erahnen was ich
damit darstellen möchte und zwar eine
kleine laterne dafür allerdings erstmal
den sand hier vorne weg nehmen und sack
und pack und dann hier auch eine laterne
dran und hier auch doch jetzt
konzentrieren wir uns erstmal auf diesen
bereich vorne wo unser kleiner fisch
plan dann hoch kommen soll dafür müssen
wir allerdings diese seetang kacke hier
erst mal kurz abstellen sagt hier ein
eben kurz hochziehen der soll einmal so
sein bitte und dann hier noch mal ein
zwei drei zur seite rüber und hier dass
man nochmal in kapellen und hochziehen
ich gucke nach rechts rüber dass ich
mich daran dass ich mich hier wieder
inspirieren lassen von einem video das
auf youtube gefunden habe da vorne ist
ein zombie endlich mal ganz gut
hier findet selbstverständlich wieder
ein
link dazu und in der info beschreibung
also wenn ihr das ganze nachbauen wollt
dann könnt ihr das entweder hier mit
meinem video machen oder einfach dort
mit dem video und der erklärung jetzt
werden gold machen kann ich gerade nicht
mitnehmen benötigt allerdings das
forderte fleisch ja auch nicht also den
goldbarren nämlich gern hier vorne noch
mal eben kurz einen drauf gesetzt hier
vorne und dann hier noch mal drei über
123 und dann hier auch noch mal eben
hochziehen
das war es dann auch schon tatsächlich
was man mit dem ganzen holz machen
mussten
die sache ist dass ich jetzt noch ganz
viel davon habe ich wünschte ich könnte
daraus jetzt auch hier irgendwelche
fichtenholz sachen machen allerdings
funktioniert das nicht
und wir müssen demnächst wirklich noch
mal rüber da sind allerdings schon
wieder ein paar mehr fichten gewachsen
also mache ich das mal eben direkt 64
fichtenholz fallschirm konnte ich mir
tatsächlich machen mit den ganzen
fichten die wir da vorne noch neu
gepflanzt hatten und wir haben sogar ein
neues bienen netz noch am start und
mittlerweile vier stück hinauf der tiere
insel was wirklich extrem krasses also
ich habe die ganze zeit gewünscht ein
wien es dort vorne zu haben schon
gedacht wo ich das irgendwann abbauen
kann eventuell beziehungsweise wo ich
noch eins gefunden habe allerdings ist
das problem jetzt gelöst wir müssen
jetzt noch die anderen tiere da
irgendwie so ein bisschen fahren
demnächst und dann haben wir auch das
fertig hier vorne das ganze auch noch
mal kurz rüberziehen zack zack zack zack
zack zack die sonne geht schon darunter
das heißt gut schlafen so ein neuer
morgen erwartet uns hier in unserer
minecraft die welt und wir können die
gelegenheit auch mal ganz kurz nutzen um
unseren einsätzen den ich gerade mir
noch mitgenommen habe hier vorne mal
wieder hinzusetzen das hier dann
hoffentlich der baum demnächst wieder
hoch beziehungsweise ich glaube ich
setze nicht dorthin ich setze hier hin
und jetzt kümmern wir uns endlich um die
finalen züge unserer angel situation
hier vorne
denn wir benötigen erst mal noch leichen
holztreppen und eichenholz stufen elfen
auf jeden fall zu wenig ich weiß habe
ich dann von noch mehr haben ihn
natürlich nicht habe allerdings menge
holz am start also sollte ich denke ich
hoffe ich mal kein problem sein
hier vorne erst mal ein bisschen hoch
bauen denn wir bekommen hier die treppen
hin so dass wir dann hier runter können
das ganze natürlich allerdings
verständlich wieder ab weil wir auch das
holz benötigen
und hier kommen jetzt so die die unsere
plattform hin wo dann der kran drauf
kommt mit unserem fischernetz man kann
zwar kein richtiges netzen minecraft
bauen aber ihr seht gleich was ich meine
taktik und sagt und jetzt hier in die
mitte einfach 12345 hoch und dann 1234
zur seite denn das hier wird unser kran
sein und an dem kran runter packen wir
nun einen holzzaun dann unsere beiden
ketten die ich ja glaube ich mir gemacht
habe und hier vorne nur gerade in der
kiste vergessen habe genau diese beiden
ketten benötigen wir und die eichenholz
falltüren die sechs stück die ich auch
hier am start habe dass sie sollen
nämlich so ein bisschen unser
fischernetz darstellen also erst mal
hier unten die kette dran und hier auch
noch eine kette dran
da kommt dann hier eine eichenholz
falltür daran und an die eichenholz
falsche kommen 123 und von der anderen
seite die vierte die wir nun allerdings
alle einklappen und dann von kunden noch
mal eine falte daran so dass das hier
ein bisschen ein fischernetz müssen den
gerade auf jeden fall noch ein bisschen
schöner bauen zum beispiel können wir
hier hinten das einfach mal so machen
hier dann eine treppe dran und dann hier
runter zack zack zack
dann haben wir nämlich so eine art
gedicht was an den kran hier vorne trägt
mit den ganzen fischen da müssen dann
aber schon eine menge fische hin und
hier bauen wir das ganze jetzt einfach
mal
und hier oben auch noch eine daran und
darunter eine treppe und auf der anderen
seite genau das gleiche also zack zack
und hier auch nochmal jetzt muss ich
nicht ganz kurze wieder hoch bauen ich
glaube es war echt gut wenn ich mit
diesem gerüst auseinandersetzen würde
dann würden wir eine menge zeit und
ressourcen immer sparen
allerdings bauen wir jetzt hier erstmal
das ganze so und zack hier vorne das
wieder abbauen und einen davon neue
hinsetzen haben nämlich hier so ein
bisschen das den den kran oben mit
führerhäuschen keine andere ob man sowas
hat bei einem schiff wahrscheinlich ist
es alles irgendwie automatisch gesteuert
ist auch beim hamburger hafen
aufgefallen nicht wahr da letztens er
ist ja alles mit computer dass er das
interessiert gerade wahrscheinlich
niemanden jetzt nehmen wir allerdings
unsere fichtenholz falltüren und setzten
die hierhin und hierhin und dann auch
noch mal hier und hier dann können wir
hier so darum klappen und das gleiche
hier auf den anderen seite auch bzw da
oben sondern auch noch einen drauf das
heißt man ganz kurz hier hoch zack und
hier mal kurz runter war mein gott da
komplett seine bitte hier an
das nämlich auch ganz gut weg denn hier
setzt ich glaube ich auch so eine treppe
transit es auf der seite auf jeden fall
ein bisschen schöner aus und hier dann
auch noch eine eichenholz stufe und auf
der anderen seite machen wir das ganze
selbstverständlich auch denn da packen
wir nun auch hier oben drauf hier eine
und dann hier zack und hier darunter
packen wir auch noch einer dann können
wir das ja auch schon wieder abbauen und
das war es dann auch schon hier von
unserer kran situation aber auch mal ein
bisschen licht und da gehen wir wieder
mit unserer steinhauer so ein bisschen
vor wir brauchen generell noch ein
bisschen mehr licht ich glaube auch ich
mache das da oben noch mal eben kurz ein
bisschen schöner
da könnte ich mit theoretisch mal eben
kurz eine fichtenholz stufe machen
sofern ich noch genug davon haben sollte
ja perfekt sagt so das holz brauche ich
gleich noch mal ganz kurz denn damit
muss ich mich hier wieder so dumm hoch
bauen nämlich und wann man könnte das
ganze hier so so und so anordnen hat mir
so ein kleines bächlein mehr oder
weniger für unsere laterne und wir
müssen hier vorne nun auch noch ein
bisschen beleuchtung anstatt kriegen das
mache ich nämlich hier einfach mal bei
unserem steg beim und bahn
und dann packen wir hier noch
beispielsweise eine laterne hin zack und
jetzt fehlen uns laternen so jetzt
sollte es wirklich reich mit den
laternen nicht nehmen trotzdem die hier
noch mal eben kurz runter ich fand
gerade das nicht so schön aus sagt dann
können wir hier vornehmlich noch einen
draufsetzen
dann haben wir hier alles so mit den
stein stil stufen vor dass ich auf jeden
fall ganz cool aus und hier vorne können
wir dann auch einfach hier und hier da
fehlt mir jetzt wieder eine aber dann
mache ich das mal eben kurz sony keine
besonders eine laterne noch mal ganz
klipp eine stufe machen dann hat mir das
ganze mit denen wird der belichtung
nämlich jetzt auch fertig hier vorne
habe ich sie das heißt bam bam bam zack
zack die laternen kann ich wieder
einpacken dass das und dass das brauche
ich alles nicht mehr und die stein
ziegel stufe mal ganz kurz hier noch
drauf denn wir haben wirklich ein
großteil schon fertig also hier unten
kommt gar nicht mehr so viel hin
das einzige was jetzt noch kommt sind
kisten und truhen überall verteilt da
können wir nämlich beispielsweise
einfach mal hier noch einfach hinstellen
dann können wir hier noch 1 hinstellen
dann setzen wir hier nicht hin dann
setzen wir jene küste hin das soll
wirklich aus dem schiffe über alles voll
steht dann habe ich auch schon gesagt
dass ich hier auf jeden fall noch eine
kiste hinsetzen möchte dann müssen wir
nun allerdings die wir hier ganz kurz
abbauen und ein tiefer setzen so dass
wir das hier hinkriegen dann möchte ich
auch hier vorne das können wir hier
beispielsweise mal machen möchte ich
auch noch eine hinsetzen wie mache ich
das jetzt wieder abbauen eben kurz unter
wasser ist alles immer ein bisschen
schwierig wie allerdings auf jeden fall
auch noch ein fast drauf wir können hier
auch noch eine stein ziegel stufe
draufsetzen fällt mir gerade noch eben
auf das ist glaube ich auch ganz groß
und davon haben wir ja auch noch hier
vorne ein paar drin also die auch noch
mal eben kurz mitnehmen dann können wir
halt hier vorne die boote immer so ein
bisschen parken zeigt also dass sie dann
natürlich hier hin und dann auch hier
vorne eins hinten ich kräfte mir noch
mal ganz kurz irgendwie so ein
fichtenholz bobin dann sieht das auf
jeden fall auch noch ein bisschen cooler
aus dass wir mit mehr als 23 45 und dann
einfach im kurs stand es zur anordnung
dann habe ich auf jeden fall zwei
verschiedene boote hier vorne am start
und schaut euch mal an wie geil das
aussieht und wer mit dann dem nächsten
angel haben und hier so stehen und
angeln
egal wer das wir dürfen uns allerdings
nicht ablenken dass meine lieben freunde
denn hier vorne im häuschen soll auch
ein bettchen sein denn es sollen hier
auf jeden fall auch villiger hinkommen
dürfen die dann hier irgendwie schlafen
und sich dann denken ja kommen dann
werde ich mal hier irgendwie weil sie
nicht was fischer wahrscheinlich weil
hier nur herum stehen es ist schon cool
aus
es ist geil wie sich unsere ganze insel
entwickelt ich werde hier vorne jetzt
einfach mal im fackeln an bringen
beziehungsweise haben wir auch noch eine
laterne hier vorne drin wenn ich mich
jetzt nicht ganz irre viele von vorhin
übrig hatten genau dann haben wir darin
auf jeden fall noch ein bisschen mehr
licht und gelegen uns auch direkt mal
hier drin schlafen denn dann haben wir
die chance einen wiedereinstieg sports
gesetzt habe
wir haben einfach zwei stunden die folge
wieder so verdammt lang nun allerdings
weiter konzentration auf unsere ganze
kisten situation hier vorne denn ich
möchte ich hier zack zack das ebenso
hinsetzen die ist aktiver gewesen aber
war nicht die hier drunter hat mir auf
jeden fall bauen und dann setzen wir
hier noch mal ganz kurz ein fässchen so
hin und hier vorne sondern auch noch
eine kiste hinkommen das ist hier ein
bisschen einfacher denn wir können das
hier direkt an den rand so platzieren
dies auf jeden fall falsch platziert
worden von mir perfekt
dann muss ich glaube ich doch ein
bisschen komplizierter machen und wieder
hier eine darunter setzen allerdings
auch nicht weiter schlimm zack und zack
einmal kurz der an der seite hoch jetzt
können wir hier auf jeden fall eine
kiste kurz hin platzieren und wir können
auch diese fallschirm eben ganz kurz
wieder abbauen so dann haben wir hier
auf jeden fall die kiste situation erst
mal fertig hier soll allerdings auch
noch ein bisschen was hin nämlich hier
einmal ein fass und hier vorne auch und
hier dann packen wir nochmal fast drauf
und ich noch ne kiste dann machen wir
hier noch eine kiste hin dann machen wir
jedoch eine kiste hin beziehungsweise
könnten wir hier auch ein fass hin
machen dann wäre es allerdings verbunden
mit dem ding hier vorne und dann packen
wir das fast einfach mal hier vorne hin
es soll wirklich komplett so aus als
wenn überall hier das so fischer mäßig
kisten und fässer rumstehen und dann
packen wir nun auch die letzte truhe
hier vorne hin denn jetzt sind wir
tatsächlich fertig mit unserer armee
hier vorne ich packe das bot ihm noch
mal eben so ein bisschen schöner in der
parkbucht sagt und jetzt kann ich das
ganze noch mal kurz zeigen also hier
vorne sollen dann so angl utensilien
reinkommen wie beispielsweise angeln
er gibt es ja nicht und dann kann man
sich hier hinstellen und können so
entspannt ein bisschen angehen wenn wir
uns dann umdrehen sehen wir allerdings
mensch hier sind dann auch die ganzen
gebäude wir haben hier vorne unsere
boote am start vor über wollen hin zu
tier insel
wir haben dann hier vorne so einen kran
am start und hier können wir die ganzen
fische lagern denn hier ist ja auch dass
fischers netz also das soll das ein
bisschen darstellen und hoffentlich
haben wir dann auch im videochat der
hier für uns ein bisschen geld ich weiß
nicht ob das so genau möglich ist sich
auf allerdings schon also schreibt und
in die kommentare
hier fordern wir unseren kleinen
rundgang um das gebäude herum um hier
vorne kann man reingehen der fischer
kann aus gucken kann mir beim an den zug
oder kann ihr schlafen gehen er hat
beleuchtung er hat kisten am start um
die wachen zu lagern und hier ist dann
der perfekte übergang zu unserem weg
hier vorne und zu unserer insel
ich finde es sehr sehr sehr sehr geil
das geile ist auch wenn man von hier so
hoch kommen und hier lange läuft sieht
man hier hinten
unsere eigentliche start insel unsere
sportinsel und hier wurde soll demnächst
endlich mal der leuchtturm hinkommen da
freue ich mich auch schon extrem drauf
wenn man dann hier hoch geht und man
wird ihr hinten von seinem leuchtturm
begrüßt hier ist das schwert dann unten
sie zauberinsel es wird alles so
unfassbar gerade auf dieser insel ich
bin megastolz auf dieses ganze projekt
in meiner lieben freunde von daher bin
ich an der stelle das heute ich mir
jetzt auch beenden wenn es euch gefallen
hat das kann einen daumen hoch unter
video her da abonniert main kanal und
klickt auf die glocke wenn der neue
videos nicht verpassen wollt wir sehen
uns übermorgen wieder in einer neuen
episode minecraft mitbekommen 20 und ihr
könnt ihr schon mal die kommentare
schreiben was ich machen soll
[Musik]